[Music]
you think you can fix me gee you are not
broken
beautiful friend the mind is a fragile
thing takes only the slightest tap to
tip it in the wrong direction
Charles what did you do I had to keep a
stable I protected her from the truth
there's another word for that I came
looking for answers you feel like you
don't belong here
you don't they can't begin to comprehend
what you are she's changing to what you
didn't come here looking for answers you
came here looking for permission
she's one range
Hey missile coming out to us Jean Laskin
fault was she still offered this is your
fault Charles but world is on the brink
I'm sorry I didn't stop it sooner you're
always sorry Charles
and as always a speech and nobody cares
they're still
don't do this
[Music]
the right to fear me I've seen evil
[Music]
I'm looking at it now they warned us
that something was coming
if there is ever an end in this forever
war it will be because of you and your
strong right hand where the line in the
sand we fight against the forces of
darkness
this is you're expecting a sign that
says secret headquarters oh I need some
ID love um are you serious you made me a
damn weapon I just wanted to help you
become the best you
[Applause]
some dudes get their kids Legos saving
the world or something does it do
anything special yeah it smashes things
real good
[Music]
you are mankind's best and only hope
especially fighting monsters not working
with them
are you calling monster pal you believe
me recently
these are just some time
[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can't take care of myself
when you're 18 give these people a
chance because that's what they're
giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real gameofthrones around here dude just
mess around you look at me and you're
like why so dark you're disabled too
austere kid you've got it all if you
could have one superpower what would you
think everybody chooses flight you know
why so they can fly away from this
conversation no cuz heroes fly well you
hear your fake family to stand up for
you hey
Billy Batson I choose you
escape
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir
wait for you okay
Shazam
Billy you're the only person I know that
knows anything about this Cape Crusader
stuff tonight yeah it's crazy right
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing okay why are you talking
guards your phone charged like a bad guy
right
you have full immunity from your dead
sorry about your window you're welcome
for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're free a race of noble boys
heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
but keep having these
memories something in my past is the key
to all of this
you're not a flatus think you'll see
that's a yes or no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
but you really are
I think I had a life here
what aren't you telling me
we've come a long way
but you know as strong as you think
[Music]
the school is just the beginning
I'm not going to fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
I've stood a cute is love thing aren't
you
what's your name understand huh
hey miss Potts if you find this
recording don't feel better about this
part of the journey use the end
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun than salads food and water went
out four days ago
oxygen allowed out tomorrow morning I've
been when I drift off I will dream bath
you it's how I see you
[Music]
[Music]
animus did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
we lost all of us
we lost friends you lost family
we lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
huh is anyone home this is Scott Lang we
met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany really big is just an old
message that's me can you buzz me in I'm
gonna ask you a series of questions I
want you to respond truthfully have you
ever heard someone yes have you ever
experienced anything you'd consider
abnormal
[Music]
yes last question do you know a mutants
are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
what is this place she's in the hospital
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being through hot get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
I shouldn't have
but I try because young
as asked me by you took me by surprise
[Music]